foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wow this is clearly The Nostalgia flock
here on the show from Disney on Ice to
Bugs Bunny at the symphony we have
George Doherty here to tell us about
this loony show coming to Las Vegas at
the Smith Center this weekend Saturday
to be exact right Saturday matinee okay
Saturday evening both wow okay now you
and your co-creator you guys
created this back in 1990. 1990 we've
been doing it of course the cartoon
started in 1930 right 1940 1950 wow
these are everybody's favorite Looney
Tunes what's Opera Doc the rabbit of
Seville
um high note uh baton Bunny these are
all the cartoons we all grew up no
matter what age we are we all grew up
with these cartoons at one point in our
lives the thing that these cartoons all
have in common is fantastic music so we
have the extraordinary spectacular Las
Vegas Philharmonic Orchestra on the
stage all 80 of them plus and then a
gigantic screen above the orchestra and
uh we do 16 of the most iconic Looney
Tunes
um and all of the music is played live
this is from our rehearsal last night at
the Smith Center and this Orchestra is
so fantastic these cartoons are so
brilliant and it just takes everyone
back to their childhood wow and then you
know besides the show obviously this is
an attraction very Vegas style it's an
attraction you guys have something
before and after the show that's also
part of the experience we have a whole
experience
um if the audience uh comes uh early
they can have their picture taken with
Bugs Bunny and the gang in the foyer of
the Smith Center we have uh all kinds we
have a fantastic animation Art Exhibit
so you can see how the cells were all
um painted by hand that's to make these
cartoons and then you see 16 of the
greatest funniest and most musical
Looney Tunes that have ever been made as
fun as it is it's also a history lesson
it's been around so long is and you know
these guys Carl stalling and melt
Franklin who wrote the music for these
cartoons they worked in their own crazy
music but they also worked in Wagner and
Rossini and let's and Tchaikovsky and
all these classical composers most of us
learned uh our classical music from
these cartoons first I'm a I've been a
conductor all my life and I got my first
exposure to classical music through bugs
and Elmer and Daffy and yeah
tweety tweety tweety will be there I
love it now this is the kickstarter to
celebrating Warner Brothers as a whole
100th anniversary Warner Brothers is 100
years old this year they were uh they
started up in uh in 1923 and uh now here
here we are in 2023 so you know
thousands of movies just these cartoons
alone there were 875 cartoons made over
that time period and we've all fallen in
love with them all over the years so I
can imagine this is the most fun you
could have at work this is the most fun
you can have a work and it's the most
fun you could have at a symphony
orchestra concert absolutely for the
whole family this one's funny we tell
everyone they don't have to behave at
the Symphony concert we like that here
in Vegas yes we like that now Bugs Bunny
at the symphony performs at the Smith
Center tomorrow shows are at 2 p.m and 7
30 p.m today